dans son ancienne immeuble son voisin
Jérémy se rappelle de lui comme d'un
garçon posé et gentil il était vraiment
doux calme attentionné mais Jérémy
s'étonne tout de même de certaines
habitudes hommes il y a beaucoup
d'hommes qui montaient
pas forcément beaucoup tous les jours
mais un deux ou trois par semaine quoi
Abdoulaye fait monter des hommes chez
lui quand sa petite amie n'est pas là
le 31 décembre à Aizenay en Vendée
la petite ville toute entière enterre un
de ses notables Roland Touzeau un élu
municipal ancien instituteur
âgé de 57 ans perd de deux enfants il
était engagé dans de nombreuses
associations de la région
Roland Touzeau était connu et respecté
de tous
il représente beaucoup pour nous dans
les Pays de Loire il faisait partie du
conseil de toute façon du conseil avec
le avec Monsieur le Maire et tout ça
alors c'est vraiment
c'est pour ça qu'attendre
les habitants d'Aizenay sont d'autant
plus choqués que les circonstances de la
mort de Roland thouzot sont terribles
le 20 décembre dernier les pompiers
interviennent dans cette rue de Nantes
car une voiture est en flamme
après avoir éteint l'incendie il
découvre dans le coffre du véhicule le
corps de roland-thuso nu et poignardé à
plusieurs reprises
un meurtre sordide qui ressemble
étrangement à un règlement de compte
[Musique]
que s'est-il passé pourquoi cet homme a
priori bien sous tout rapport a-t-il été
sauvagement assassiné
au début de l'enquête les policiers font
face à une énigme
[Musique]
Aizenay une petite ville de 8000
habitants à quelques kilomètres de
Nantes
[Musique]
c'est ici que vivait Roland Touzeau
propriétaire soigneux de cette maison
[Musique]
Roland Touzeau était père de famille
séparé il avait deux grands enfants qui
n'ont pas souhaité rencontrer deux
journalistes
ancien instituteur il était engagé dans
la vie de sa commune
depuis des années Roland Touzeau était
conseillé municipal d'opposition
Joël Blanchard était le chef de sa liste
divers gauche il le connaissait depuis
30 ans
cet article est paru le 18 décembre oui
soit deux jours avant la disparition de
Roland tozo lorsque nous avons pris la
disparition tragique de Roland nous
avons suspendu cette campagne électorale
suspendu nos actions pendant
quelques temps voilà en signe aussi de
respect pour Roland mais parce que nous
n'avions pas non plus la force de
nécessaire pour poursuivre son absence
se souvient d'un professionnel compétent
et consciencieux
pour lui ce meurtre paraît totalement
inexplicable
vous savez
l'assassinat d'un ami dans des
conditions sordides
ça bouleverse et c'était un tendre
quelqu'un qui n'aurait pas fait de mal à
une mouche personne ne lui connaissait
l'ennemi
pendant son temps libre le citoyen
modèle Roland Touzeau multiplié les
activités
concours de villes fleuries mais aussi
compétition canine
sa grande passion les Shetland ces
petits chiens de berger
Michel barbe avait connu Roland Touzeau
au club national de cette race quand il
a vu la tête à harmonie était fière il
me dit oh là là qu'est-ce qu'elle est
belle
il participait au concours ensemble
[Musique]
quand je veux je pense à mes Shetland à
la douceur de mes chez tande à la
gentillesse de mes Shetland c'est ça me
rappelle complètement relance en fait je
trouve que Roland et le Shetland c'était
une belle combinaison quelque chose qui
allait bien ensemble
allez zou la dernière fois que les deux
amis c'était vu c'était 5 jours avant le
meurtre à une de ses compétitions c'est
le dernier beau souvenir que j'ai de
Roland oui c'est on a passé une journée
sensationnelle ça a vraiment été
extrêmement agréable de sourire de
plaisir et grâce à Roland j'ai pu
obtenir la première place avec Galway
une victoire heureuse mais ce jour-là
Michel remarque un changement dans le
comportement de son ami
il avait les traits tirés tu lui dis tu
as l'air bien fatigué il m'a répondu oui
je suis crevé il est temps que les
vacances arrivent
Roland Touzeau est tendu il n'est pas
dans son état normal
cache-t-il un secret Michel lansera pas
plus comme tous ses proches elle ignore
tout de sa vie personnelle il était très
discret il protégeait ce qu'il aimait
son entourage et non jamais je jamais
jamais on a eu il nous a dit quoi que ce
soit de sa vie privée
un homme secret pour ses amis et sa
famille impossible d'imaginer qui aurait
pu lui en vouloir
[Musique]
pour tenter de trouver une piste les
enquêteurs se rendent au domicile de la
victime
lorsqu'il consulte l'ordinateur de
Rolando ils font une incroyable
découverte
l'homme fréquentait les sites de
rencontres comme celui-là il y ait
changé essentiellement avec des hommes
et la personne avec laquelle il était le
plus en contact ces derniers temps est
un très jeune garçon il s'appelle
Abdoulaye il a 20 ans 37 ans de moins
que Roland Touzeau le jeune ivoirien un
sourire charmeur et des allures de
Playboy
Abdoulaye aime s'exhiber sur le net il
montre son corps et pose avec sa copine
Annie 23 ans chez qui il habite
[Musique]
sur ces vidéos que nous nous sommes
procurés Abdoulaye est à gauche sur
l'image
on y découvre un garçon fêtard et un
souci
Abdoulaye aime la danse la musique c'est
un jeune homme comme les autres
Abdoulaye filme ses séances de tatouages
je respire bien
passionné de football il fait inscrire
sur son bras le nom de son joueur
préféré
[Musique]
dans son ancien immeuble son voisin
Jérémy se rappelle de lui comme d'un
garçon posé et gentil
c'est
lui qui m'a installé la boxe il s'est
quand même dévoué pour une proposer ce
qu'il avait la même je me suis dit que
qu'un mec comme ça il y a pas de
problème il était vraiment doux calme
attentionné mais Jérémy s'étonne tout de
même de certaines habitudes du jeune
homme il y a beaucoup d'hommes qui
montaient
pas forcément beaucoup tous les jours
mais un deux ou trois par semaine quoi
Abdoulaye fait monter des hommes chez
lui quand sa petite amie n'est pas là
quelle est la nature de sa relation avec
Roland Touzeau est-elle simplement
amicale s'agit-il d'un de ses anciens
élèves
avant de trouver une réponse à cette
question la police va relever des
tranches dépenses faites avec la carte
bleue de Roland Touzeau sur Internet
quelques semaines avant sa mort il
achète une chaîne hifi une friteuse et
d'autres objets en tout ils dépensent
4000 euros
seulement voilà renseignements pris
aucun de ces achats n'a été livré chez
lui
ses objets arrivent directement au
domicile d'Abdoulaye de quoi intrigué
sérieusement les policiers
le 2 janvier au matin le jeune homme est
arrêté et interrogé au cours de sa garde
à vue Abdullah est reconnaît qu'il est
bisexuel il révèle qu'il est l'amant de
Roland Touzeau depuis plus de deux mois
concernant les achats livrés chez lui
Abdoulaye explique que Roland Touzeau
lui a donné sa carte bleue pour qu'il
s'achète des cadeaux
mais pour l'avocat de la victime maître
cabioche c'est impossible
l'hypothèse qu'il est plus remède
spontanément sa carte bleue c'est
quelque chose qui étonne les proches de
Monsieur touso c'est quelqu'un qui était
très attentif à sa situation qui était
très rigoureux dans
sa dans la gestion de ses comptes c'est
ce qui amène effectivement les proches
de Monsieur Touzeau a pensé que cette
carte lui a peut-être plutôt été
subtilisée
une semaine avant le meurtre Roland
Touzeau fait d'ailleurs opposition sur
sa carte bancaire
cela n'arrête pas Abdoulaye
il a alors une autre idée pour trouver
de l'argent
il décide de mettre en vente sur
Internet la voiture de son amant
une voiture de luxe
il espère ainsi récolter plusieurs
dizaines de milliers d'euros
face aux policiers Abdullah raconte
qu'il s'est senti pris dans un engrenage
il sait que son amant refusera la vente
de sa voiture
il aurait alors décidé de l'éliminer
[Applaudissements]
le soir du 20 décembre Roland Touzeau ce
serait rendu chez Abdoulaye
le garçon lui aurait porté deux coups de
couteau thorax
Roland
blessé aux mains puis au cœur ce dernier
coup aurait été fatal
le lendemain à l'aube est un complice
Abdoulaye aurait placé le corps de son
amant dans le coffre de sa voiture
il serait allé la garer plus loin à 2 km
de là dans un endroit isolé en bordure
de Nantes puis il serait retourné chez
lui à pied pour nettoyer la scène du
crime
le soir même vers 18h il serait revenu
sur place et aurait mis le feu à la
voiture
c'est rendu compte en fin enfin mais
bien trop tard évidemment de la gravité
de ce qu'il venait de commettre à
l'évidence il souhaitait essayer de
faire disparaître les traces et indices
quelques minutes plus tard les riverains
préviennent les pompiers qu'une voiture
est en train de brûler
Roland touzor est donc été la victime
d'un banal crime crapuleux
mais pour l'avocat d'Abdoulaye
l'histoire n'est pas aussi simple il ne
s'agirait pas que de sexe et d'argent le
jeune homme aurait une relation
affective avec Roland Touzeau
il y avait effectivement une connotation
sexuelle incontestable il y avait
au-delà de ça je crois travers ses
aventures là avec des personnes plus
âgées peut-être des choses un peu plus
profondes des choses un peu plus basées
sur des relations de confiance ou de
conseil
mais l'avocat revient sur un autre fait
qui pourrait selon lui expliquer l'issue
tragique de cette relation
le jeune homme sans papier ne travaille
pas or il a un gros besoin d'argent
car depuis quelques semaines il a appris
que sa compagne Annie atteinte un enfant
de lui
c'est quelqu'un qui
a été extrêmement angoissé par cette
idée de devenir père c'est cette crainte
de ne pas être à la hauteur de ne pas
pouvoir assumer financièrement cet
enfant qui selon lui a motivé ou fenêtre
en tout cas l'idée de commettre l'effet
qui lui sont reprochés
Abdoulaye mais elle a été relâchée aucun
élément ne l'impliquant dans le meurtre
elle est mise en examen pour une affaire
d'escroquerie sans lien avec la mort de
Roland Touzeau le jeune homme lui a été
incarcéré à la maison d'arrêt de Nantes
si l'après méditation éprouvée il risque
la prison à vie